saint jude's ranch for children is  making some progress on a center  dedicated to victims of sex  trafficking it is located in boulder  city not too far from hoover dam  the healing center is on a 12-acre plot  of land it will have six homes and up to  60 residents can live there at one time  nothing like this currently exists in  our state but the need for child  trafficking services do continue to grow  this dirt lot will be transformed into a  place of healing  so that we can help young people not  just move from being  a victim and not just identifying them  as a victim  that's not enough we need to help them  be a survivor  but that's not enough we absolutely need  to help children and young people become  thriving community members  january is human trafficking prevention  month on the 11th you are asked to wear  blue to raise awareness  the official opening date of the healing  center has not yet been announced